joining us now the man who got it all
started the author of the number one
bestseller clinton cash
the untold story of how and why foreign
governments and businesses
helped make bill and hillary rich and
from the government accountability
institute peter schweitzer
former deputy assistant to the president
sebastian corker
um if i remember i think i did the first
interview for clinton cash on radio and
tv
peter correct or no yeah you're exactly
right sean from the very beginning
that's right
and and you warned us about this and you
said there's about 145 million in
kickbacks to the clinton foundation
total yeah that's right 145 million
dollars that we know about
comes from a variety of sources but it's
basically nine shareholders
in this uranium one company guys like
frank giustra
sergey kurzen and and others and uh
there's there's a major story to be told
there
not only about how this deal was
approved but how this deal was put
together
and the fact that the clintons made a
lot of money by
basically helping the russians to corner
the world uranium market and that's what
vladimir putin set out to do
our fbi knew it our department of
justice knew it
and they still let it happen that's
inconceivable that's right sean and
yeah and let's add to that list by the
way hillary clinton knew about it i mean
as i point out in the book and anybody
can go to wikileaks and look at
there were state department cables
classified that came out in wikileaks
that were going to hillary clinton
top secret that were talking about the
fact that the russians were looking to
corner the world uranium market they
were active in kazakhstan they were
active elsewhere
and that it was a strategic goal of
vladimir putin
to try to grab as much of the world
uranium market as possible so
she was informed about this she knew
about this and apparently didn't care
all right dr gorka i don't know any
other way to say this
anybody that will give away uranium
to the hostile actor and if you don't
believe putin's a hostile actor
and russia is a hostile country listen
to hillary's own words
and listen to every democrat listen
everybody in the media what they've been
lecturing us about with their phony
trump-russia collusion story america's
national security
was severely compromised here and we had
a chance to stop it
and not only did we not stop it they
made money on it
i don't know i i don't know any other
way to describe this
except they sold out our security your
reaction
sean uh first things first we owe you a
debt of gratitude we owe peter
we owe sarah carter for not giving up
first things first we've got a lot of
territory to cover number one
again the president was right let's just
start with that
he was right if there's any collusion
it's on the other side
secondly massively important point this
story is not about
opposition research this is about
corruption it's about collusion and
potentially
treasonous activity members of the obama
administration at the cabinet
level as there was an fbi investigation
of racketeering on uranium by russia in
america
approved this deal hillary clinton
approved a deal
that would give 20 percent of our
uranium to a nation
like russia that supports rogue regimes
this is massive sean you think back i
remember
donald trump took a meeting donald trump
jr
one meeting he says he didn't even
remember who was in the meeting because
i asked him
and the media went insane they're still
bringing it up
right hillary clinton gets 145 million
he gets twice his normal speaking fee
he wants to meet with nuclear officials
he's paid by a bank with a financial
interest
in uranium one oh that's not a big deal
to anybody else in the media
i i i can't stomach the fact
these people are so in the tank in the
media
in this profession supposedly it's
despicable what they're doing to the
american people you can't trust them
and not only that look at the writing
yesterday
by molly hemingway at the federalist how
many stories
are out there in the media that came
from fusion gps
this isn't just the only story they were
working hand
in glove with the liberal media your
audience needs to know that
fusion gps was making stuff up about
president trump and
feeding it to other journalists but the
last point here sean
the only reason we have muller
investigating the president today
is why because james comey briefed the
dossier to the president
and within minutes that was leaked to
cnn
right now we have to have the aeg
cancel muller's mandate because the
dossier was full of russian propaganda
from russian agents
and was fallacious it was a lie all
right
muller is culpable but you think mueller
is culpable
yes without a doubt he knew without a
doubt he actually he had to know
he had to he's and eric holders signed
off on the deal
he had to know that this was a bogus
dossier he had to know it
because he knew the sources secondly
why was he paying michael steele why was
the fbi
paying michael steele for the phony
dossier the propaganda
the misinformation and the lies that
were fed to the american people
uh that were tried to be used the
russian phony dossier to
influence an election all right peter
back to you the one talking point you
hear is
and even like liberal joe and all these
idiots in the media
you know they're out there saying wow
the fusion
uh gps uh first was uh hired by some
republican donor
but the fact is it was prior it was
general op
research prior to christopher steele who
went to the russians
paid for the lies that the media and the
democrats spread on donald trump to
lie to the american people
that's exactly right i mean look the
problem with this dossier is not only is
it inaccurate
and wrong but when it first came out
there was no corroborating or
substantiating information
what you have with uranium one and the
clinton scandal is
you have the actual transference of
money nobody disputes that all this
money went to the clinton foundation
you have the decision made to give the
russians the uranium
these are facts that are not in dispute
so and that's i think the problem that
first
yeah go ahead finish finish go ahead i'm
too worried i was going to say that you
know that's what i think
what i think was so frustrating to
people is when you look at this if
you're going to look at russian
uh you know penetration or a trumps at
collusion you got to have the same
standard when you look at both sides and
they clearly haven't and that's why it's
they sold out america's security
for money true or false yeah
and they knew about it absolutely and
they knew about it sean
they were warned about it this is bigger
than watergate the president said this
is water
this isn't watergate this people will
forget this when
when the clinton corruption case is
finally laid to rest when this criminal
cartel it pays the ultimate penalty
for what they did to america's national
security we're going to forget what a
gate ever happened
but right now right now we have to find
out who inside the doj
under eric holder who's inside the fbi
we're going to find out
who made all right peter you should take
a bow
two years ago on this program you broke
this story